Sophie how are you I'm good thanks kind
and how are you I'm great you're staying
safe you're you're quarantined yeah it's
very very safe very very quarantined
loving it I mean obviously this is you
know a lot of bad news out there but you
like this business of staying home don't
you yeah I mean I'm an introvert I mean
I'm a homebody I just like I if I could
stay at home all day I would so this is
great for me I leave the house like once
a day anyway to walk my dogs and then
that's it so nice yeah I mean I don't
know how people are I see how people are
finding it difficult but I I don't
understand how people are really
struggling to practice social distancing
right like we have to do is stay at home
and like get drunk at home no wait a
minute I've been listening to doctor
foul Qi on CNN and nowhere does he ever
say just get drunk at home yeah but you
know he's thinking it you know he's
doing the same thing yeah half the time
I see him on television he seems tipsy
yeah that face mom
yeah mom facepalm yes do you like the
fact that I mean you've been on my show
many times you're always very
beautifully dressed this must be this is
a real change for you you look gorgeous
but you can kind of just wear anything
do you like this I love this this is
great isn't it like you don't have to
get dressed up I'm wearing my sweatpants
oh wow oh yeah I'm like I'm hot I'm
business on top party on the bottom
right I'm reading in the paper that
couples are having a hard time being
quarantined together how are you and Joe
getting along um yeah I heard the
divorce rates were up Joe and I it's
actually kind of everything seems to be
working out in my favor here because
Joe's like he's a real social butterfly
so I struggle to kind of lock him down
and I haven't just spent time with me so
it's kind of it's like prison for him
but it's great for me like I'm sure it's
not prison for him but how does he pass
the time what does he do he's
taken up like a Instagram like DJ set he
started doing that DJing at home yeah
he's did really really loudly when I
read my scripts he's DJing at home like
the other day yesterday or the day
before he was due he did like an 80 set
for a good pot like two hours eighties
music for two hours mm-hmm yeah okay
that would be rough I mean there's some
great 80s music and then there's other
80s music I don't think I could hear
soft-sell over and over and over again I
know well you're like you know in this
house really okay and while he's DJing
what is your role how do you support him
um I pull him his drinks I pull him his
alcohol I give him tequila shots he'll
like text me and be like what time is it
and then I'll reply from the kitchen
shot time and bring him some a shot
tequila he's curious what time is shot
time does it have to be like after 5:00
[Laughter]
it's fun it's really fun and like I get
to dress him up according to what kind
of the theme is of the DJ set so 80s I
dressed him up in like some this like
windbreaker that was very colorful and
very 80s and I think the next one's
gonna be I think he's thinking a reggae
music so I don't know I don't know if I
have the right the right attire for that
but I'll see what I can do I can ship
you over some stuff I know that you have
the right stuff I have all the right
dress reggae all the time hey baby
all day that's my thing when when I'm at
home you know yeah do you find that do
you think that you dress more
comfortably at home than Joe does yeah
definitely because he's like I mean this
is this is something that's I only kind
of come to my attention since this
quarantine thing but I saw him it was
like a meme online or someone some
comment or something and someone said
like if you're wearing
denim pants at home like what does that
say about you during denim during the
quarantine at home when no one can see
you no one can see what does that say
about you as a person like you that's
like a bad yeah Joe does that Joe well
as denim trousers at home no one can see
I'm I'm not I'm not wearing denim
trousers yeah yeah who's dressed up I've
been days I know I I also I can relate
to Joe cuz I've been wearing jeans a lot
and sometimes I look up and I think why
am I doing this well I did that to your
groin kind of well I'm Catholic any
punishment any punishment down in that
area that feels right to me
let it fly